here in Europe another attempt today in
Brussels to save the Iran nuclear deal
from unraveling Germany France and
Britain have called for dialogue amid
increased tension in the Gulf region
between Iran and the United States Iran
on Sunday said that it would restart
talks if the u.s. lift sanctions and
returns to the 2015 deal meanwhile Iran
has resumed enriching uranium beyond
3.5% that's a breach of the deal but
what does it mean well for light water
reactors three point five percent
enriched uranium is needed in research
or shipped reactors the uranium has to
be about 20 percent enriched
weapons-grade uranium is enriched at at
least 85 percent the extent to which
Iran is permitted to enrich uranium is
at the heart of the nuclear deal on July
14 2015 the international community
uttered a joint sigh of relief the
signing of the nuclear deal with Iran
was the beginning of a new chapter in
relations with the country I think this
is a sign of hope for the entire world
and we all know that this is very much
needed in this times this is that
defined by we have reached an agreement
that will make the Middle East and the
world a whole lot safer it is a step
away from the specter of conflict and
towards the possibility of peace after
almost a decade of negotiations Iran
agreed to get rid of 98% of its enriched
uranium and to reduce the number of
centrifuges in exchange for relief from
international economic sanctions the
deal established a new relationship
based on transparency but by no means
trust this is a bilateral agreement if
the other signatories comply we will
make sure we do the same in January 2016
international sanctions on Iran were
lifted after the International Atomic
Energy Agency certified the country's
compliance with the obligations
established in the nuclear deal this
time the sigh of relief came out of
Tehran
the capital of an oil-rich country
driven to the brink of an almost total
trade embargo in place since 2006
everything seemed to be going according
to plan
until Donald Trump came onto the stage
he disliked the Accord from the get-go
slamming the Obama brokered deal was an
important part of his campaign rhetoric
once in power he followed through on his
promise to pull out of the agreement we
cannot prevent an Iranian nuclear bomb
under the decaying and rotten structure
of the current agreement therefore I am
announcing today that the United States
will withdraw from the Iran nuclear deal
since then the US has reintroduced all
the previous nuclear-related sanctions
against Iran along with other punitive
measures as a tit for tat Iranian
government announced that it will stop
abiding by some of its commitments and
requested that the remaining signatories
ease restrictions on its banking and oil
sectors as that failed to happen by its
July 7th deadline Iran announced it
would breach another limit by raising
uranium enrichment further unraveling
the landmark deal for more I'm joined
here in the studio by Benin Ben Tyler
blue research fellow at the foundation
for defense of democracy a u.s. foreign
policy and national security think tank
which opposed the 2015 deal and has
advised the Trump administration welcome
to the program thank you for joining us
we have a Ron saying that it's ready for
dialogue if sanctions are eased and just
yesterday European powers are calling
now also for talks reiterating that call
shouldn't the u.s. and Iran head back to
the negotiating table I think that's
absolutely right
I think the Trump administration despite
putting massive financial economic and
some would even say military pressure on
the Islamic Republic is looking to get
Tehran to come back to the negotiating
table Tehran has said some of these
different preconditions has shot a
couple of drone has shot a drone out of
the sky has fired on tankers they're
using mines Iran I think is trying to
get the conditions ready for it to
eventually come back to the table
because I think it knows that it
eventually will have to come back to the
table but I mean just yesterday and I we
have to address this a British news
paper publishing these leaked memos from
the former UK ambassador to Washington
essentially saying he claims that Trump
pulled out of the nuclear deal with no
plan on what to do next does the United
States have a plan well the plan seems
to be to use exactly the same sanctions
exactly the same tools that got us to
the jcpoa nuclear deal but again once
you get to the table to broaden the
issues that the administration has
talked about these twelve points I'm
sure that you know it's not just a
nuclear issue it's the missile issue at
the military issue the terrorism issue
basically what has made in sustained
Iran an international pariah for the
past 40 years the qualms that we have
again as an institution with the jcpoa
nuclear deal is that it only addressed
the nuclear threat and it didn't even do
that quite well so now that there's an
opportunity to regenerate the pressure
to get Iran to come back to the table
why not broaden the issue set and see if
you're on blinks first but you know
there's a saying you're you're throwing
the baby out with the bathwater right
what is your long-term goal here is the
government looking for regime change for
example in Iran
there's definitely been people in
Washington who've been talking about
regime change but I think the Trump
administration remains committed to
getting a bigger broader better deal I
think even last summer as you saw some
pretty fiery tweets exchange between
Iranian and American officials the
administration has been committed to
getting grow hani did a negotiating
table to talking with iran and i think
it's been quite unprecedented to see
such financial pressure coupled with a
desire to talk if anything Tehran may
try to abuse this desire to talk to up
its leverage and to make American want a
deal more than it needs a deal why what
you're talking about this bigger broader
better deal I mean what maybe makes you
so optimistic that you might get that
because I mean when we're seeing the
situation currently on the ground I mean
just in the past month
we saw this plan for US air strikes on
Iran Trump calling it off at the last
minute I mean the tensions are rising in
a way that is concerning the
international community how do you see
the dangers in the region of
destabilizing Iran through this policy
well the funny thing is that Iran is the
one destabilizing the region I think
it's important to have the causal chain
correct here Iran is a trying I think
trying to get leverage it knows that he
can't outlast this pressure policy for
the first year of max pressure it
thought it could outlast the trump
administration now it's trying to create
leverage trying to up the anti do things
that actually would make America
in return to the negotiating table and
appear to want to deal more than two
everyone needs a deal
so yes Iran does have these
destabilizing policies which proves us
and the international community to come
together not have this transatlantic
divide that currently exists and attempt
to present a united Western Front to
deal with these issues diplomatically
what do you make of the European efforts
because I mean EU foreign ministers are
meeting in Brussels later today and and
you've put them in a bit of a sticky
position here haven't you
well the Europeans for the past few
years before the u.s. pulled out of the
nuclear deal defended the jcpoa as if it
was the best thing since sliced bread
and now I think they're beginning to
realize that yes missiles should have
been included yes there's some flaws
with a deal the sunset issues should
have been addressed in fact there was a
six-month period from January to May of
2018 when the Europeans and Americans
had a transatlantic dialogue over how to
fix the deal that process unfortunately
faltered but it's something that can be
resurrected and if the Europeans do want
a diplomatic agreement to stem Iran's
nuclear program
the Americans want to have pressure to
get Iran to the table then there is
space there to actually collaborate and
bridge that transatlantic gap the
question is will the Europeans turn a
blind eye to Iran's nuclear violations
and container decide with the world's
foremost state sponsor of terrorism
against their major Western liberal
international partner been event Le Bleu
thank you so much for joining us with
that view we appreciate it